foreign
[Music]
I'm assuming you're not with anyone
never see you with anyone
[Music]
that's it Mom and Dad
yeah
they died
before I was 12.
I'm trying to write about them at the
moment
how's it going
strangely
hi
this is real
does it feel real
are boys back home
awesome
look at you you were just a boy
no you're not
[Music]
it was a long time ago
yeah I don't think that matters
[Music]
I've always felt like a stranger in my
own family
[Music]
I'm always scared of something
always running away do you remember
[Music]
it's funny it doesn't take much
to make you feel the way you felt back
there again
[Music]
I'd always fall in love
this is a new feeling you
than me together
[Music]
into the world